kenji after a nail-biting week of
competition Ken Jennings is officially
the Jeopardy goats taken 15 years for
Ken Jennings to finally answer the
question is he as good as he appeared to
be in that great run on Jeopardy so what
does can win a cool million dollars but
his opponents James Holzhauer and Brad
Rutter aren't walking away empty-handed
they're both getting 250,000 bucks Brad
so yeah ken is the old-time jeopardy
champ but all three guys hold their own
unique records Brad he's won the most
money in the show's history 4.6 million
dollars and James he's got the record
for highest single day earnings and
let's call a spade a spade James also
probably holds the record for snarky
astre marks James yeah you no need to
rub it in we'll get rid of those scores
right now we will of course add them to
whatever they hey Brad scores still on
there
not only do we treasure these three
iconic players we've also got host Alex
Trebek on our hearts and minds as he
continues fighting his battle with Stage
four pancreatic cancer how are you
feeling how's everything going little
tired no time the fan support has
through our office people on social
media everyone in the audience tonight
was on their feet clapping and cheering
what does all that support mean to you
it's blowing me away I told somebody the
other day that most of us in our
lifetimes never get to know the impact
we've had on other people you only hear
about it after the person passes away
and to be able to experience it while
you're alive is very special and people
have been so kind in all walks of life
sending cards letters offering advice
their prayers and I mean I have had so
much holy water sitting on my debts from
Lourdes and other places where pilgrims
scope that it just it touches me at a
very deep level and it's it's an
experience that on one on one hand I
didn't want to experience and on the
other hand I'm glad it has happened to
me because it has taught me something
about where I stand